this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers blockbusters
summer this episode is sponsored by
Google play with the help of black
desert mobile from two dudes who built
your childhood by riffing on the stuff
that built their childhood these
visionaries at the height of their
powers will collaborate to achieve the
impossible make a guy look cool in a
fedora m'lady the Indiana Jones trilogy
prepare for three near-perfect adventure
movies Raiders of the Lost Ark a film
that's perfect in every way
except when it implies the heroes up
with a child I was a child I was in love
it was wrong and you knew it Temple of
Doom a film that's perfect in every way
except for all the racism and the Last
Crusade a film that's perfect in every
way
as the ending to this hero's journey
except for the fact that it wasn't and
it still isn't let the man rest there's
already two over this been Raiders it's
the mileage he can't even get it up for
an interview these days who shot first
grade or huh I don't care Harrison Ford
stars as dr. Indiana Jones
he's not just a terrible professor
he's also a terrible archaeologist and a
tomb of Sir Richard you saw him well
what was left of him who discovers
temples that would completely changed
the way we think about ancient cultures
then Rob's there as blind and turns them
into rubble
[Music]
he's a crop top and booty shorts away
from being a Tomb Raider but Andy's not
alone along for the ride is his high
school crush Marion as in she was in
high school while he was pushing 30 and
alcoholic who's just as tough and smart
as Indiana and she's captured and she's
captured again and guess what that's
right captured the not so lovely Willie
Scott that's more food than these people
eat in a week
who screamed her way through the entire
sequel and into the directors heart we
have so much in common
she hates bugs and I find that
entertaining and Sean Connery in a dual
role as both Indiana's father and his K
brother santoku Schmidt come on guys
Sean Connery at sex is not a twist enter
a mystical world where Judaism is real
an offensive version of Hinduism is real
and Christianity is real
but the hero is an atheist I don't
believe in magic a lot of superstitious
hocus-pocus man ignoring the
supernatural is kind of Harrison Ford's
things hokey religions and ancient
weapons are no match for a good blaster
at your side kid
and trot the globe on these non-stop
thrill rides determined to give you
every possible combo of action bad
versus man car vs. car cards versus cars
bike vs. bike boat vs. boat horse vs.
truck horse versus train horse vs. tank
plane vs. playing playing versus car
plane vs. bird man versus larger Man Man
verse bridge man verse Paul member-state
kippers kid goes first man members car
and man vs. is in scene after scene of
masterfully directed set pieces with
real characters stakes and clarity of
movement that today's filmmakers took
one look at him went not too hard
let's just fill the screen with a bunch
of CGI puke it'll be toe including Lucas
and Spielberg
so enjoy a franchise that's the American
answer to James Bond where instead of
being suave cool and efficient he keeps
getting his cover blown the fuel a
Scottish law then I am Mickey Mouse
getting robbed this time it will cost
you what was briefly yours is now mine
you give me the diamond this is the
second time I've had to reclaim my
property from you it's called bluffing
all the time Renee Suzy will doesn't
have any real impact on what happens in
his own movie and makes it pretty clear
you either die a hero or live long
enough to be the bad guy in a Black
Panther movie how do you think your
ancestors got these that belongs in a
museum
story antica Jones
[Music]
out of control Karen caught on video
Sallah the old young Indiana Jones
chronicles I don't know why
Belloc swallowed that fly Big Willie
style screw mutt
this is ND son finish human fatality
just let it go Elsa Elsa
dan aykroyd creepy-crawlers Miracle Whip
hitting Nazis good hitting women and
children bad hitting sean connery and
open hundreds lavish dr. Hyde and
Harrison Ford and real-life
[Music]
adventuretime actors are always shorter
than you think
but they said that staff is exactly five
feet tall Oh cute little guy this
episode is sponsored by google play jet
black desert mobile and discover more on
Google Play now if I had yelled cut on
time those actors would be alive today
nobody is perfect I'm nobody
so I'm perfect Marty whatever happens
don't ever go to 2020